what happened to your ig
man heartbroken that's that's the rp
date
that's august 24th i'll never forget
that because you were dming me and i
didn't even know yeah i didn't even see
it because it just and i hate that [ __ ]
because it's like i'd be dming i'd be
dming all the people man and it's like
i can't get mad at them when they
overlook it like like me just follow me
and he unfollowed me i'm like what the
[ __ ] is you on he like snap i thought
this [ __ ] was fake [ __ ] this this yo
page i'm like yeah cause i just vanished
i don't know i guess when instagram had
that disabled when they was taking
everybody [ __ ] it may end up taking
miles but i literally didn't do nothing
like it was it was just crazy you
weren't getting violated or nothing man
i wasn't doing [ __ ] like my violations
came from instagram first when the guns
and all that i ain't post guns in years
i don't know that [ __ ] no more so like
for them to just take my [ __ ] down it
was just like yeah you bullying you
going against i'm like what are you
talking about my last post was me giving
book bags out to the kids shout outs on
my brother we was giving the boot bags
out to the kids to go back to school
before my fight and they get it my guy
freddie gibbs has had uh
10 instagram pages in the last year they
took his official one down and he just
keeps making new ones and then they
finally i can't keep doing that here
trooper i ain't going
i think he's just throwing the hat in i
think he's just like i'm on twitter
[ __ ] like like i ain't gonna lie that
that ain't that [ __ ] hard bro i had
almost a million bro like and i worked
that was my core fan base right there
like so just to get that [ __ ] snatched
away from you it was like you gotta be
hard that [ __ ] worse than getting you
got them jury snack you know take the
jewelry yeah you can go [ __ ] [ __ ]
over preventing [ __ ] from doing that
you can't do nothing like it just
you can't can you can you get like uh
like will they like re-verify you or
because i'm trying to get re-verified
right now because it's like at this
point i don't need to give i ain't
tripping about the page no more because
when the page got took it was doing my
fight so i was stressing and i'm
thinking like i'm like damn bro like i'm
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] i gotta start back over but then i
really said to myself like now i don't
have to start back over everybody in the
world everybody in the industry ain't
gonna say everybody in the world most of
the world and everybody in the industry
know who snapdog is right so it's like i
ain't no new artist i just gotta they
gotta find me so now they just are
finding me back and now i gotta get the
blue check the because it's a lot of
fake pages of me so that blue check
don't let them know that it's me